non c'est pas je te jure si c'est pas
possible non mais c'est qui j'ai eu des
candidats agité son plateau mais là on
est amis l'ont quand même un très bon
challenge
voilà décidément peu dans les rayons
allez-y allez-y
on mélange bien servi de leurre pas
encore mais le voir mais c'est quoi ça
tous les matins on continue alors c'est
à vous de jouer un petit mélange désiré
je suis pas moi je vois du régime
51 51
c'est hallucinant si c'est ça c'est
énorme
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même hyper bien fait plus tard on me dit
souvent je ressemble mal à l'entendre la
réforme à kad merad [ __ ] c'est
incroyable et c'est quand tu parles
habitat si c'est toi c'est génial
allez on fait un dernier mot enfin parce
que j'ai besoin quand même d'être d'être
fixé couilles c'est courir c'est aussi
ll es quoi mais oui c'est toi y'a pas à
dire reparle un petit peu la foufoune
bon ça y est c'est bon
cyril quoi ces bouffons sors de ce corps
cyril été reconnu à temps je vérifie à
temps c'est pas je te jure si c'est pas
possible
non mais c'est qui paye je sais pas je
me suis à leur écoute quoi
célébrant dingue la gêne est en débat
b-spec walla maintenant par la nation
dont vous tirez vous de charisme
personne ne sait à présent elle ajouté
calme-toi tiennent leur nom mais qui
vous poursuivent ils
nous nous y voilà
j'ai tout fait pour moi
[Applaudissements]
puis quand j'ai tiré et inquiétait à
temps j'étais au maire des risées car en
la production de voitures à john lennon
qui fait est exceptionnel indien au nord
est et à patrick alors est-ce qu'on peut
revoir juste coup de karaté surpasser 40
fois ce week-end faut le revoir il faut
leur dire regardez ça c'est après falla
je veux maintenant great téléphone qui
sonne rico est désigné combat c'est un
comédien john eledjam qui travaillent
chez nous depuis maintenant quatre
sorcières merci d'arrêter d'en sodagri
lyonnais midi là avec moi partout il
avec moi sur l'émission de canal aussi
que vous avez vu puisque vous avez adoré
non je suis désolé là j'ai vraiment vu
je peux vous raconter toute l'histoire
mais je reconnais dans les guignols
embrasse très fort key
[Musique]